so it's lithium lithium is the top the
alkali metals lightest of all of them
it's very very reactive we use it a lot
in organic chemistry to activate
carbon-carbon bond formation but you can
see here is a very very dark colored
metal it's actually really nice and
shiny if you cut it fresh but it reacts
with nitrogen in the air to form lithium
nitride really really quite quickly so
lithium is the lightest metal it's a
very light element it will float on
water then of course it does react with
water as well so we're going to take a
small sample and again we're going to
see what happens when we react it with
water okay
it has had a number of quite important
applications in the last few years some
of you will know that lithium is used
treating what is now called in the
bipolar disorder or manic depression
the lithium itself is stored under oil
to stop it reacting with with with the
air and also with water so we're just
going to clean off all of the oil now
before popping it into there to the to a
sample of water and in fact I think
though I'm not a great expert on pop
songs there's at least one pop song
called lithium based on this so here we
have the dried lithium which you can see
this is metal we're going to drop it
into the to the water and let's see what
happens and it'll fit around a little
bit
so you see the lithium reacting quite
rapidly with the water and you can see
hydrogen gas being evolved now if we
catch that hydrogen gas in a beaker or
in a in a test-tube we could then ignite
it or burn it but lithium is very
reactive one of my colleagues said that
if you have a fire with lithium you can
never put it out
you can see freshly cut lithium there
nice shiny metal but as it reacts with
the nitrogen forms a nitride which is
black it reacts with nitrogen in the air
it's one of the few metals that will
react with nitrogen spontaneously so
that if you have a container of lithium
which has been exposed to air it tends
to smell of ammonia because it is
reacted with nitrogen and then the water
in the air reacts with the salt that is
formed and you get a smell of ammonia so
it smells a bit like dirty nappies
you